[Musique]
bonsoir isabelle sékaly nos êtres
présidente d'honneur de l'association
commerciale iroise et bonsoir à vous
également frédéric jeanjean
restaurateurs secrétaire générale de
l'umih 13
on est proche des 6000 cad en
réanimation en soins critiques
regardez ces chiffres on voit que lors
des deux derniers confinement on était
sur des chiffres bien plus bas
aujourd'hui les commerces non essentiels
devraient rouvrir le 15 mai c'est ce qui
est annoncé en fonction d'ailleurs des
territoires idem pour les terrasses à la
mi mai et les restaurants peut-être en
totalité dans certaines régions comment
vous avez accueilli ces mesures qui sont
annoncées dans ce contexte sanitaire
très tendu isabelle c'est calinaud alors
déjà chez jamais pourquoi nino vieira
occupée on a cependant lancé une
campagne d'envoyer des chaussures usées
est trop petit pour les enfants à nos
ministres ou qu'ils comprennent bien qui
semblait une somme essentielle et puis
nous inquiète en doublement parce qu'on
se rend compte que tout ce qu'on appelle
servir à rien ou fermées pour quoi faire
puisque toute façon vous continuent
toujours avoir des problèmes de santé
et d'après de pouvoir recevoir tous des
malades à l'hôpital
donc je pense qu'il ya eu un souci
important de faire quelque chose sans
réfléchir
quand j'ai appris que les sex-shops été
ouvert dans paris là j'ai rebondi jeudi
mais c'est pas possible on empêche les
enfants d'acheter des chaussures et les
adultes de changer leurs chaussures qui
sont des fois bien usé et on fait rien
pour nous donc on s'aidera décidé
quelques-uns dont nos collègues nous
envoyer un message sur facebook en
demandant on aura des chaussures à
nommer les choses qu'on a fait donc
lundi à hier les gars puis de notre mère
nous avons été les trois collègues
d'envoyer des chaussures à nos ministres
ou qu'ils braquaient pas et simplement
une question de mode les chaussures
c'est essentiel frédéric jeanjean à
votre niveau
comment est ce que vous envisagez
justement
cette potentielle réouverture des
terrasses et puis peut-être des
restaurants dans certaines régions en
fonction justement du taux d'incidence
des dans les différentes calendrier que
nous avons pu aborder avec le
gouvernement il nous avait été dit que
quand le président de république
parlerait il y aurait trois semaines de
délai pour ce prêt à la réouverture
nous sommes ont conduit à la fin du mois
d'avril
il n'a toujours pas pris la parole la
réouverture 15 mai semble fortement
compromise il va falloir voir l horizon
cela va s'amorcer en tant qu' une
réouverture
ça se fait pas en claquant des doigts je
vous rappelle que nous sommes nous
dépendant de notre de nos filières
derrière il ya donc vous avez les
agriculteurs les éleveurs et producteurs
on va pas du jour au lendemain décidé
d'abattre je ne sais combien de têtes de
bétail ou de volaille ou deux points ce
soir
ça prend du temps pour se préparer il ya
toute la chaîne logistique
c'est à dire qu'il y a les transporteurs
et les commerciaux ou la prise de
commande et il ya tout ça qui doit se
mettre en place ça se fait pas en
claquant des doigts
le président la publication la semaine
de préparation
pour l'instant il a toujours pas pris la
parole nous attendons de voir comment ça
va se passer
alors justement le medef parce qu'il ya
quand même des jours fériés qui
s'annonce l'ascension le 13 mai et le
meddat fait pression pour une
réouverture dans lesquelles un ou deux
des commerces avant dès le 10 mai même
pour permettre justement de reprendre
une activité qui soit
lucrative avec des chiffres d'affaires
de bons chiffres d'affaires en
perspective pour vous ouvrir le 15 mai
éventuellement c'est trop tard mais déjà
trop tard nous passeraient de 3 v après
c'est trop tard et puis nous avons
respecté nos saisons parce que les
commandes prochaine qui va nous arriver
c'est l'hiver
oui dans quelles conditions va être
question de stock question de trouver de
la place pour mettre nos boîtes de
chaussures
donc si on n'ouvre pas le 3 mai on est
tous morts n'est pas dû qu'au ville
comme aura mais j'ai bien d'une crise
qui a été mal jugé mal fait et vous êtes
prêt à réouvrir version donc sarments
restaurateurs qui ont besoin d'un peu
plus de temps frédéric jeanjean ben oui
tout à fait ce que je vous disais il
nous faut un peu de temps pour nous
organiser parce que vous imaginez bien
que nous avons toute une logistique à
mettre en place
je vous donne un exemple très concret
très simple avec les ouvertures et
fermetures successives que nous avons vu
dans l'établissement qui est un
établissement qui a été ouvert en 1886
s'il tombe bien marseille quelque chose
d'assez connu historique et bien lors
d'une interview avec un de vos confrères
on me demandait quels étaient les uns
les effets immédiats j'ai dit c'est très
simple mon établissement acolytes de
guerre mondiale survivra pas à cinq ans
de gestion technocratique macro nist
vous savez je voudrais un exemple
concret mon comptoir avec les fermetures
il a fallu à chaque fois coupé
l'électricité et bien les frigos qui
était dans l'eau s'est évaporée dans le
plancher
les frigos se sont décrochés puisque le
bois qui les soutenaient à sécher donc
il faut changer tout le comptoir
maintenant donc ça c'est des
investissements s'est pas pris en charge
par les assurances s'est passé vraiment
changé par personne et un comptoir ça
coûte cher
j'étais cet après midi chez des
confrères c'est les frigos qui ont lâché
à force d'être allumé et éteint la
lumière les prix les moteurs ont lâché
donc là il ya ces problématiques là
derrière la problématique des
marchandises ensuite la problématique du
personnel parce que nous étions avant le
problème de l'épidémie dans des
situations tendues
terme d'emploi et aujourd'hui nous nous
rendons compte que nous avons salariés
qui font défection pour une simple et
bonne raison ils ont réussi à trouver
des emplois dans d'autres secteurs
économiques qui leur permettent d'avoir
le salaire à 100 bursa et donc ils ont
eu des changements d'orientation
professionnelle
on va avoir une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
à laquelle va se rajouter derrière la
problématique des apprentis qui depuis
un an n'ont pas eu de stages pratiques
et n'ont eu que de la théorie et vont
arriver à la réouverture dans nos
établissements sans savoir comment
pratiquer comment procéder alors que les
techniques étaient acquises au fur et à
mesure du temps sur la stratégie
justement du gouvernement déconfinement
progressif territorialisée surtout vous
par exemple frédéric jeanjean est ce que
vous êtes à marseille ce que vous
espérez pouvoir rouvrir ou pas mais on
va être très simple s'il faut attendre
une semaine ou dix jours de plus dans
nos métiers nous attendrons mais par
contre une fois que nous ouvrirons il
est hors de question d'envisager que
nous fermions ensuite à nouveau au fur
et à mesure avec des couvre-feux avec un
pas de deux un cours n'avancent homme qu
un recul et au final on va se retrouve
au tribunal de commerce
alors maintenant ça suffit alors nous
partagerons les a transférés lino est
tout à fait d'accord ça suffit on a été
c'est pas crier les uns et des autres
donc il faut qu'on avance et qu'on nous
vous tous il qu'on puisse vivre
je trouve que l'état le propre à côte
notre détresse parce qu'on est fatigué
on en a ras-le-bol
il tournera que les mesures de sa
stricte maria ça suffit il faut avancer
tout vivre je n'ai à ces îles et permet
sans arrêt de recommencer ça nous
apporte rien de nouveau alors c'est un
effort pour qu'on puisse tous vivre les
restaurants fermés c'est une adhérence
total les cinémas fermés erronée d'un
écran nous on chausse des personnes on a
dans nos boutiques c'est tout petit
d'accord oui nous avons toutes les
mesures nécessaires
j'ai rien trop tôt alors pourquoi je
fermais pourquoi nous punir toujours les
mêmes les pauvres les petits je devais
vous entendre sur la communication des
manuels macron il était à melun il a
lancé des pistes un bon rien de bien
certains finalement est ce que vous
auriez préféré qu'ils attendent le 5 mai
pour s'exprimer et donner je dire une
les grandes lignes définitivement tout à
fait parce que moi je trouve qu'on n'est
pas des enfants
donc ça nous dire des choses clairement
on veut qu'on disparaisse complètement
avec ans mais cette possibilité que ça
soit les restaurants les bars que tout
disparaisse
oui quoi concrètement on achète dans ce
qu'elle annonce ou de commerce
mais qu'on ne joue pas au chat et à
souris on ne peut plus je vous avoue
qu'on est tous dans un état de détresse
complète
je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de bandes
de pau vide en connectant de continuons
comme cela mais aura aussi beaucoup de
commerçants qui vont se trouver très mal
après si un jour on peut vivre
normalement
justement c'est encore un petit peu flou
tout est incertain concernant le
calendrier de réouverture ça dépendra
évidemment de l'évolution de l'épidémie
d'ici les prochaines semaines
mais le gouvernement en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il promet un
protocole sanitaire strictes frédéric
jeanjean à quoi est ce que il faut
s'attendre
bon il ya des certainement les gestes
barrière qui seront encore évidemment en
vigueur mais est ce que vous vous
attendez vous à de nouvelles règles
a priori le protocole sanitaire qui
devraient être appliquées lors de la
réouverture est celui que nous avions à
l'automne dernier juste avant la
fermeture
mais il n'y a quand même un élément
qu'il faut souligner nous sommes tous
fermés tous pour éviter que l'hôpital ne
soit en tension
nous ici à marseille nous avons la super
d'apprendre que delhi avait été fermé à
l'hôpital alors on dit qu'il faut éviter
de l'hôpital son attention et on ferme
les lis et je pense que c'est à peu près
pareil partout en france
alors vous savez je vous dirais
l'échangé le bonne fois pour toutes à
partir de maintenant je vais franchir un
seuil
je veux franchir un cap et je vais
rentrer un peu dans le débat politique
et je vais m'identifier aux candidats de
la république en marche puisque nous
sommes non essentiels il va y avoir des
élections
journal et des élections cantonales eh
bien je les reconnais tous les candidats
tous ministres quels qu'ils soient élus
locaux ou autre quand vous des candidats
et les hommes et femmes politiques nommé
essentielle je suis social c'est-à-dire
non essentiels c'est à dire on n'a pas
besoin d'eux puisqu'ils sont pas
capables de pas donc on n'a pas besoin
d'eux alors il ya le 5 mai bon kevala le
mettrons petit va s'exprimer est ce que
vous attendez de sa part qu'il prolonge
les mesures de soutien à la reprise et
le maintien des aides en cours et que tu
es quand on parle des aides pour une
belles paroles mais c'est une parole en
l'air
croyez moi je ne recevrai rien donc il
la plupart de nos commerçants qui sont
des personnes qui ont un stock énorme
notre métier fait qu'on est obligé
d'acheter d' avance donc six mois
d'avancé
nous avons des énormes stocks on pourra
pas les payer donc ça sera l'industrie
de la chaussure qui va être mal après
nous donc quand on entend des aides ça
me fait rire parce qu'en fait finalement
si les tout petits êtres qui ne savent
même pas payer nos loyers ni rien donc
arrêté par les déserts nous avons pas
besoin d'être nous revenons travailler
c'est tout bête mais nous voulons
simplement gravés hausse en prison on
sent pas libre il tint sa tenue et puis
les clients ne comprennent pas après ce
que vous attraperez en disant ne fait
rien on se suit qu'on peut pas niveau
jeu chaussée et comme pour les
restaurants il disparaît mais pourquoi
on peut pas ils ne comprennent pas en
fait
et moi non plus je ne comprends pas des
mesures qui ne sert à rien en fait
parce que quand j'entends que ça
continue à augmenter dans les hôpitaux
qui a de plus en plus de malades etc à
quoi ça a servi de serre mais pourquoi
faire tant rien donc je pense qu'il faut
il trouver une autre solution
oui la guerre on a des nations qui
prennent depuis le mois de janvier à
ouvrir et ben non le ferai exprès l'état
ne le permet pas donc voyez quand on
veut faire avancer des vaccins vont
commencer au départ les petits qu'il
faut pas attendre que les grandes villes
donc non je te parle
je ne comprends pas et on al'impression
poney je dirai je ne veux pas parce que
je veux pas attaquer politiquement
celui-ci ou celui-là mais je trouve que
mise à part aux élus qui lui défend et
qui est toujours proche de nous personne
d'autres s'occupent de nous bon alors
j'ai justement les élus pour terminer là
dessus à mâcon qui s'est entretenu avec
une dizaine de mer cet après midi
justement en vue de ce plan de
déconfinement progressif et
territorialisée frédéric jeanjean est ce
que vous croyez que les élus vont être
écoutés parce que ils ont déjà eu des
consultations avec le président quelle
volte face rappelez-vous au début du
mandat
comme tous les corps intermédiaires
avaient été méprisés alors ce que je
veux vous dire au niveau du territoire
ici dans les bouches du rhône c'est que
ce soit le département la métropole la
région
tous nos élus ont été à nos côtés nous
ont accompagnés quelles que soient les
étiquettes politiques et quand je disais
tout à l'heure je reconnais comme non
essentiels et candidat à la république
en marche
il ya quand même en dehors de ces gens
là ces gens non essentiels quand je les
reconnais comme nous non essentiels il
ya quand même un choix politique très
large de la droite à la gauche et de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
maintenant
ces gens qui ne sont pas capables de
gérer qui se retrouvent en situation de
fermer des lits ils se retrouvent en
situation de ne pas avoir de mars qu'au
moment où il impose de les mettre qui se
retrouve à ne pas être capable mettre en
place une stratégie
rappelons nous monsieur salomon qui
avait oublié de commander les masques à
l'époque tous ces gens là qui nous donne
des leçons et qui se permettent
d'arriver et de nous mettre sous cloche
ça suffit basta est entendu merci à vous
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs
secrétaire générale de l'umih 13 et
merci à vous également
isabelle se câlinent au présidente
d'honneur de l'association à commercial
l'iroise merci m